anyone in this room learn cursive when
they were in school
do the whole room shout out to
Millennials and Boomers gen Z not in the
room because they're like what's a
cursive they no longer are teaching
cursive in school but I found that
content creation is the world's newest
language you can learn the language of
content creation or you can have like a
translator but it's just gonna cause you
to move slower if you go on vacation and
you had a translator with you I would
deem that kind of frustrating every time
you're trying to communicate you're
gonna have some trouble but if you knew
how to speak the language you can
navigate the land better right